the process of locating a partner we can
love is famously so hard it may for a
long time disguise an alternative even
more complicated reality that whatever
we claim it would be a lot easier for us
if we never found a partner the hurdles
of dating undeniably exist that doesn't
mean that they aren't also being
gratefully used to hide mostly from
ourselves a harder to mention wish to
remain on our own consciously we may
tell ourselves that we would dearly love
to land on a compatible partner inside
we are hard at work ensuring we won't
and for a variety of hugely
understandable reasons because it's
simply too painful to Hope because we've
realized that we have too much talent
for identifying people who then go on to
torment us because we've had enough of
other people's Madness and too much
experience of our own because we end up
feeling that humans are probably best to
be enjoyed from a distance because
recovery from a love that promised a
future can rob us of too many of our
remaining years because we've understood
finally how properly difficult we are to
live with because no one is as perfect
as the many attractive strangers we will
never speak
to because longing alone can be so much
more gratifying than a scratchy
day-to-day reality with someone else
because if we never love we cannot be
hurt because there has to be a limit to
how many times we can be expected to
take off our clothes in front of a
stranger and last and not least because
we didn't have the sort of childhood to
develop the right instincts for this
this game but as these are all very
difficult thoughts to own up to to
ourselves and our friends we may prefer
to disguise our true intentions behind a
choreography of well-designed accidents
love would have been delightful it was
just that we chose people who we knew
would be busy we failed to call back
those who were Keen we left the party
before most people arrived we've
declared that they're all boring and
unattractive we disappointed others
before they stood any chance of
disappointing
us as a result we can continue to
experience with security one of the most
risk-free of all beliefs that we would
love to love if only we found the right
person we may be denied a partner but we
can hold on to something yet more
precious a sense of safety and a sure
belief that the appropriate candidate
would if they arrived be capable of
solving our suffering there may be few
stronger Romantics than those who manage
carefully and sometimes perhaps even
wisely to steer clear of anyone to be
romantic
with